what's happening there reject nation if you've
clicked on this video because you're excited for
multiverse of madness leave a like that would
be so appreciated so we got a few things to
discuss today first off downloaded this video
haven't seen it yet but apparently it's patrick
stewart perhaps confirming that he's actually
in multiverse of madness enough for the shannada
goodness i wanted to talk about how this could
actually open up the door for hugh jackman to
return as wolverine i have a little bit of a
theory greg's been putting out some theories
lately and i got a small one that i want to share
with you guys of how it could actually work and
not discredit the events of logan that's have i
got your curiosity all right let's go into this
the commercial comes on for a marvel movie
in which someone kind of sounds like you
how quickly does your phone go off and is there
any part of you that thinks i really just want
to watch the game i i i wasn't prepared for this
well i had my phone turned off as it happened and
so i didn't hear anything it wasn't until the next
morning when i woke up and looked at my phone and
found that i had been bombarded with the responses
and that my pr people had sent me reactions that
they had uh they had detailed and passed on to me
and um i actually didn't recognize my own voice
it sounded different whether i had
a cold or something at the time
but i was astonished all they saw was the back of
my shoulder and i think my earlobe nothing else
that there would have been so many connections
made um but i it it uh it pleased me
so you could take out this look like i just got
the goddamn scoop gotta wait for the exact right
time to drop this information he just said did you
recognize my whole voice right there yeah that's
pretty much him confirming it maybe kevin feige
was like you don't you don't have to deny it man
you're in the the trailer that's the pretty good
conference it's the reason we used to we don't
want people not to see it it's fine you don't
have to worry we're far past alfred molina now
you're a veteran you can do what you want it's
not some andrew garfield situation you're here
to replicate the level of multiversal hype that
the spider-man trailers got out of the older
spider-man villains like please tell people you're
in the movie interesting medium we're living in
now where we just don't believe anyone anymore
that's pretty much a confirmation but guys listen
we already knew that patrick stewart was gonna be
in here let's talk about wolverine really quick
now there's been a lot of reports coming out as
of late there might be a wolverine who shows up in
doctor strange multiverse of madness but it will
be a different actor playing wolverine it could
be the new version for the mcu could just be a
variant from one of the many multi-verses i think
if they were to bring in a wolverine i don't know
which one would be more acceptable for audiences
like should it be the the new this is our way
of introducing you will verin is like is it too
much to do in this new movie to like here's where
we're establishing our brand new wolverine amidst
everything when the main takeaway should be you
know all the other cameos you know it should be
scarlet witch all right like dr strange in the
main story i saw some people passing this around
and i couldn't quite find the actual source
of this but it got me thinking of how it could
actually work because i started thinking about
the timelines with logan and doctor strange multi
versus madness because i saw people saying hugh
jackman said he would return to patrick stewart
returns and i've been like googling trying to find
like where did hugh jackman say this and why do
people believe this i can't actually find that
piece of information so if you guys find it if
you want to link it in the comments that would be
very much appreciated because i personally can't
find that piece of information but then i started
thinking about wait a minute if we look at the
events of patrick stewart in logan that movie took
place in 2029 specifically and there's been a lot
of theories like is patrick stewart charles xavier
is he actually you know a variant is he from the
x-men animated show is just some different
is he from the fox x-men universe seems like
the most exciting thing you would pull is pull
them from the fox x-men universe but will that
undo the events of logan no because doctor strange
multiverse of madness is reported to take place in
2023 so when you're looking at the actual years
like you could actually see a scenario because
there's such a time jump in the x-men movies
from the last time you're with charles xavier
specifically patrick stewart to when you see him
in logan where he's got that brain degenerative
disease that's caused him to have these effects
where he's like killed some of the x-men off and a
bunch of people as well including you know so he's
at this really some ritualist time in his life so
i'm like whoa you could even if that theory lines
up of that a lot of people have now shared what
if there was like a scarlet witch or wanda event
that happened in the fox x-men universe that we
just didn't get a seat what if something like that
actually took like repercussions or damage to him
in what occurs in logan but then again you
know it's like if patrick steward you know
gets offed in multiverse and madness then i'm
like that totally throws all that afterwards
yeah yeah absolutely i mean i do it's a compelling
theory because i can see a way especially if where
you don't mess with the timeline yeah where you
were i feel like that would be the best the only
way for for me that fans would accept a both the
return of of patrick stewart xavier and the return
of hugh jackman's logan would be yeah it's in a
way that is not only respectful to the current
timeline but that maybe even also has some kind of
clever way of embellishing that existing timeline
and feeling like it's not only a fun inclusion but
also essential and i wonder if maybe they might do
both as a means of tempering that you could get
a little bit with hugh jackman have him be you
know the the requisite sort of uh fist-pumping
appearance in the mcu we've all been hoping for
but then also take it as the opportunity to do
like a low-key screen test for whoever you might
be considering to be the next logan or wolverine
and two i mean i personally have been sitting
here wondering what if we get more than one of
some of these people what if they're teasing us
with a patrick stewart and then the idea that
you know if that quote you mentioned is true
that hugh jackman would come back if he's involved
what other versions of them might we see and how
many i feel like you know it's not the point so
we're not gonna see a million but we could see a
couple you know especially as dr strange traverses
and especially as he deals with the illuminati who
are clearly you know some of the most powerful
beings in each of their respective universes and
probably carry that across some of their variants
i feel like yeah there's a broad spectrum of
possibility there's a whole lot you can do because
yeah the common theory now is that you know what
if there were mutants already in the mcu yeah new
rockstars totally did their video first right yeah
like that's the common theory that's been going
around so this wouldn't be like a a combination
of the fox universe and marvel cinematic universe
going forward yeah we would just like bring back
the mutants everywhere were just supposed to be in
the marvel cinematic universe you could still like
send back logan and patrick stewart so that
way their movie still plays out yeah yeah
yeah they're still relegated they still exist
leaves them on their timeline don't do something
where they like snatch wolverine right as he's
about to die or something like that yeah and
be like you know we own you again do something
where you can place them back when everything is
concluded by the end you know but that's just a
little side thought that i had yeah there's been
reports about like hugh jackman meeting with
kevin feige which i believe that kevin feige
with everything what they've been bringing back i
could totally see kevin feige just being like dude
what do i got to do to get you to do it i will do
anything like we have your prices we already got
the original spideys if we can get you back oh my
god this movie will break the box office all over
there's been reports about him trying to get him
back for secret wars specifically which actually
seems more likely than for actually multiverse of
madness you know i'm not eliminating hugh jackman
returning for a cameo especially because they did
work together on the first x-men movie i think
that should be a good full circle but guys what
do you think about all this leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button and we will catch you guys soon